[Música]
es una leyenda del rock y ha tomado
posición sobre la desinformación sobre
las vacunas contra el 19 en su página
web en il jong escribió los siguientes
sobre la plataforma de streaming
spotify se ha convertido en el hogar de
una desinformación sobre el virus que
amenaza la vida mentiras que se venden
por dinero la polémica comenzó después
de que el músico estadounidense leyera
una carta abierta de 270 médicos en la
que se pedía spotify que estableciera
una política contra la desinformación en
concreto por su podcast el número uno la
experiencia de joe rogan rogan que firmó
un contrato de 100 millones de dólares
con spotify en 2020 ha sido acusado en
repetidas ocasiones de promover teorías
conspirativas y difundir mentiras sobre
los tratamientos de kobe 19 en diciembre
entrevistó un virólogo que también ha
sido acusado por difundir información
falsa sobre las vacunas el episodio fue
retirado de youtube según sus políticas
y twitter bloqueó la cuenta del biólogo
pero spotify no ha tocado el episodio
fue entonces cuando a principios de esta
semana jung se pronunció en una carta a
su discográfica dio un ultimátum a
spotify le escribió pueden tener arrogan
jung
y esto a pesar de una potencial pérdida
financiera para el ideólogo de éxitos
como heart of gold y harvest moon desde
el ultimátum spotify comenzó a retirar
la música de neil young el gigante sueco
del streaming dijo que lamenta la
decisión del músico mientras que voces
críticas dicen que spotify ha preferido
el dinero en lugar de salvar vidas sin
embargo la controversia va más allá de
neil young incluso de spotify plantea
cuestiones de libertad de expresión
seguridad pública y la responsabilidad o
no de restringir la desinformación